Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now there's been another major update to the game since the last time that I played and it actually involves a
lot of different things.
Uh, but first off the names as usual. The first one goes to 'Darshita Chopra', who suggested the name "Tiny Boat Tim"
and "Tiny Seamoth Tim" for the, uh, Seamoth that's gonna happen.
But, there was another person that suggested the name, "Tiny Bubble Tim," and I'm kinda- kinda keen on that one.
And then the next one goes to 'ShnufflePuck,' who has an amazing name. Uh, and he or she said, "I think your
red hair is pissing all the fish off, that's why they're attacking you. Just like how bulls are attracted to red."
And I dunno how true that may be...
But I think it's just because I'm a human in the middle of an ocean, an ALIEN ocean, as a matter of fact, and
they keep adding updates to the game that adds more horrifying creatures because in this particular one,
called "The Power Nap Update,"
they added: beds, battery chargers, power cell chargers,
*loud screeching horror music*
AND HORRIFYING MONSTERS!
Anyway...
Last one goes to 'Doctor Derp' who said, "That's what you get for cheating."
Now I don't know what he's referring to exactly, he or she...
BUT I DIDN'T CHEAT!
I did not cheat! I've been doing it very, very nicely. I haven't had any cheating happening at all.
Well either way. So there's a lot of updates that have made to the game, uh, battery chargers, power cell
chargers, BEDS... which I dunno what that means if you can take a nap but I haven't even found the bed
blueprint. I actually went around and I tried to find a lot of blueprints. I did get, uh, if I look up here I got the
battery charger, and I have the power cell charger. And it looks like they take pretty identical things.
And I have mmmajority of these...
I'm pretty sure so I'm gonna whip up, the necessary stuff to be able to make one of these...
right off the bat and hopefully I'll be able to show you guys something new, almost immediately!
Wouldn't that be wonderful. Wait was that copper wire it needed?
Ah shit. Okay good.
And then glass... all this basic crap that we've gone through a million times. I'm gonna make the battery
charger first because I've made... I- I haven't exactly made power cells and I don't need them just yet but.
Definitely need the battery charger because that means, god it means finally I wouldn't have to waste the stupid
crap over and over and over again.
Endlessly wasting the same amount of batteries. Having to, make them over and over again.
And I gotta go get table coral, GODDAMMIT.
IT'S AN ENDLESS STRUGGLE FOR CORAL.
Eh fuck it I'll take the Seamoth out.
I'm gonna put you in the Moonpool eventually. Did I build a Moonpool?
HAVE I NOT BUILT A MOONPOOL YET?! Goddammit, I'm so far behind on everything.
I don't even remember where I left off in the last episode. All I remembered is that there was a new update that I
had to get through.
And I gotta explore the goddamn ocean.
Where is my goddamn silver? There it is.
Thank you. Okay so this.
Make the computer chiiiip.
I just need a bit more titanium.
And then... WALA-WALA-BING-BONG!
We got a battery charger!
HOOOT....
DAAAAAAMMNN! Aw I thought that this was gonna be faster that but apparently it's very slow.
But with this! Finally!
I can take the used battery that I have here and you can charge up to four at once.
And of course it takes power from your building but apparently not that much power.
That is amazing!
OH FINALLY! I won't have to charge, I won't have to make a new one every single time!
Oh man that's recycling. That's caring about the environment. That is, dutifully making sure that
everything in the surrounding area is gonna be a-okay for you.
And now...
There is a power cell charger that, when I need power cells, that'll be important. But that goes...
primarily in the Cyclops, because the Cyclops runs off of... six! I believe six power cells so, you need one IN
there and then you need a nuclear reactor in your Cyclops. And then hopefully, the Cyclops has been
beefed up enough such that it's good.
Now I don't know about that, but I'm hoping that. So, anyway.
The next thing that I'm gonna be doing is I... am going to be going... to- oh shit.
Okay you just play your didgeridoo over there I'll be gone. I'll be back! Love you, Karen. Alright, whatever.
Karen loves to didgeridoo. It- it's her favorite passion.
Okay so if I put this on now...
Alright I'll get- I'll use the, uh, rebreather once I'm actually down below... and need it.
But I'm gonna be exploring now because I need to find the bed blueprint. That's gonna be my next objective for
this game, and then in the next episode I'll get the Cyclops all ready for you guys.
And have that a-okay on everything that I need there, but for now!
I need to get a bed. Because that's one of the new features! And the only other feature in the last update
that I need as far as I know...
is probably gonna be...
Oh that's right! I need the Lost River! Oh I totally forgot about that. Yeah. I need to get the, uh, the depth upgrades
for... my Seamoth. Number one: I need to get the depth upgrade. Which is gonna be important, but also I need,
uhhh, to find the Lost River because that's gonna be a very, VERY interesting thing in the future. And that is a
"crevace [crevice]." That might even be the Lost River, holy shit where am I?
Yeah I think so because the Lost River ties into that biome with all the stringy and, like, horrifyingly
disgusting creatures of the deep.
But I'm not going there just yet. Death is not going to encroach me... until a little bit later.
But for now I'm gonna be exploring, and trying to find... all the lovely things in the horizon.
HU-BUUUUH!
Okay.
So the reason I'm going by the ship is because... I'm not 100% sure on this one.
But I imagine there would be beds in structures that we, as humans, have made because that's important so.
Where else would there be beds but on the ship, or possibly in sea bases that are abandoned around the place.
Hello big guy.
So either...
I find...
the... things that are, like, the broken off pieces of the ship, which might have something because they have
lockers in there and they might have beds.
Which is- I think that's less likely but the alternative is that on the ship itself...
is the possibility of a bed. So I'm gonna find that out and I'll be back when I find it.
Ny-ah ha ha ha.
Hiiii.
You something I can open?
A-HA!
WHOA HELLO!
Hi!
Anybody home? Oh probably not.
Ohhh booy.
Wow this doesn't look good.
Oh this looks like the opposite of good.
Well what was the point of this?!
"Sealed door. Cut open to access?" Oh goddammit. I don't have my, uh, I don't have a welder.
Ah I guess I gotta get that next. Okay.
I'LL BE RIGHT BACK! I'M GONNA GET THAT AND I'M GONNA COME BACK RIGHT HERE!
Because I know it's got goodies in it. AND I'M GONNA FIND 'EM.
Just as soon as I go find th- the crash powder.
(singing) IIIIIII WILLLLLLLL FIIIIIIND YOOOOU SOME DAY. DON'T POOP ON MEEEEEEE.
Please tell me there's something down here.
HELLO?!
(in an accent of sorts?) Is anybody going to explode? I probably shouldn't have brought my Seamoth all the
way down here.
(still in odd accent) But I don't want to drown.
Okay...
Move this to the five...
(briefly uses odd accent) Get this out. Use the laser cutter.
HA-BAH!
Is this- oh there we go! Wow. This is gonna take a while. This must be some door. I mean, holy shit.
Oh that's cool!
Oh that's cool!!
What is behind here?!
I didn't even know that we were gonna run across this oh-
Okay...
Alright, place your bets on what's behind the door!
I'm willing to bet a bed!? Ha ha ha!
Or there could be dead bodies.
That's always a possibility because night time just approached.
And that probably means the denizens of the deep... are gonna rise from their graves.
AaaannnnNNNND...
Oh, also... bonus option: absolutely nothing.
*sound of metal clunking*
Ah! Whoa! Look at that!
Bye! Okay!
Coooooool. Can I go through here?
*gasps* Hello.
Hi! I bet there's nothing special is there.
OhhHH GOD. YOU ARE KIDDING ME?
YOU ARE GODDAMN KIDDING ME!
WHAT A LOAD- I WENT- GODDAMMIT!
What the fucking fuuuuuuck!?!?
Oh that is dickitry.
OHHH THAT IS- there's nothing. It's empty!
There is nothing!
What a load of shhhhhhit.
OH.
What a bag of... dicks!
Oh that is such ass!
Ohhh
ffffuck
off!!!
Goddammit. WELL.
THAT WAS A BIG ASS WASTE OF EVERYBODY'S TIME!
Okaaaaaay, I guess we're moving on! That was absolutely nothing. I was excited for no reason
at all.
That wasn't there before.
Is there gonna be another thing to cut open in here?
That's filled with disappointment?
Probably.
Well let's see.
I don't even think I can cut this open, can I?
Whoa. Oh, came out at the wrong time there.
Ah good, yes, a door that I... pretty sure I just came from.
Oh- who build this shit!?
HUH?!
Who's tryin' to fool me that this is actually something important to cut through?!
What a load of a- I am- I'm pissed. I'm- I'm legitimately pissed because now, my welder- er, er my laser cutter is
half outta battery...
Is there something down here? No!
Something up there? No!!
Something through there? NO!!!
Load of bullshit, that what it is.
Alright.
I thought I w- I'm disappointed! I'm disappointed because I thought I was gonna be able to show you
guys something cool that I... come across. Something interesting and fun, and "neato-weato," and nothing happened.
Goddammit! Okay I gotta go back home.
Ehhh it's a bitch and a half but I gotta go back. I wasted too much power.
Well that was a waste of a trip. I gotta build the Moonpool, that's the number one thing that I gotta do
right now because... I can't keep replacing the power cells, especially considering I didn't build the power cell
recharger. So I need to...- I'm gonna go back! I'm gonna build the Moonpool! I'm gonna build the power cell
recharger because I forgot...
Uh, actually no I w- if I build the Moonpool, I won't even need the power cell recharger. So I gotta do one or the other.
I don't know...
I don't knooooooow!
Ooooooh... Whooaa... What is this?
Wait a minute, what the fuck is this?
Whoa... what the shi- hEY, back off a second there.
What the fuck is even happening here?
Wha-?
What am I looking at? This doesn't make a lot of sense. It's just kind of all raised up and... what the f- what the fuck?
Is there, like, something that's not spawned that's supposed to be here or is this actually like this?
Whaaaat the fuck?
I'mma scan this because I want this but whoa...
That is... bizarre.
I have a funny feeling that one of the, like an entity didn't load something, but there is...
There is something not right going on here.
What the fuck?
Okay...
Goddamn I really do need to just, like- like swim through the entire ocean because there's a lot of stuff...
around here that I...
do not know. Like I literally just don't understand it because I haven't seen it yet.
Like I haven't- I haven't... swam through the entirety of the newly updated open- ocean.
Like the reason why I started this new save was so I could get to all this new terrain data, that I just literally
have not seen yet so it's actually gonna be really cool to be able to go through it all.
Which I will... in time...
Okay, so I'm back home and what I gonna do is I'm going to build the Moonpool, and that requires a lot of crap
doesn't it?
'Moonpool: Titanium Ingot...' Ah that's not bad, that's just a lot of titanium.
'Lubricant' I can get from right over there.
Yeah. Okay, this ain't so bad. I just gotta go get it.
Which means I gotta get a lot of titanium.
AhhhhhhfFUUUUUUCK.
(singing) IIIII LOOOOVE FAAAAARMING! IIIIT IIIIIS REEEEAAAAALLLY FUUUUUUN IIIN MYYY OWN
WAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAY...
Habada-boop-boop-boop-boop-boop! Badaba-boop-boop-BOO-BOO-BOO! YABADOOP-boop-BA-BA-BOW!
I go a little out of my mind when I'm farming. Like literally I go completely out of my- HUP!
I go completely out of my mind.
*tch.* But in a good way, he ha hA HA HA HA...
Right up- oyy oh- ah, riiight... there.
Euuuuuuuuuuuuugh, yeah that's the stuff.
Yeaaaah.
Yeeeaaaaaaah!
HABOOSKI!
Nice! Okay, so that reduced the strengths of it but at least we got what we need! Which is good, um, so now...
I just gotta dock the Seamoth... who has seen better days...
We're gonna pop this bad boy in here- huh wonder what it's standing on.
And then it's gonna charge up and I'm gonna... frickin' get another welder, I guess.
(murmuring) I don't know where the other one but...
Ha-ba!
Oh that was nice and silent. Well shit.
Ha-boink!
Okay!
Ahhhhhhh...
*multiple computer voices all at once: Warning- Emergency power only/All primary systems online*
*screaming*
This... is like the scariest background music for an underwater horror movie that I've ever heard in my entire life.
It's kinda amazing. I appreciate it.
*chuckling* I mean, my god. What the fuck?
Holy crap
*multiple computer voices all at once: Warning- Emergency power/All primary systems online *
*multiple computer voices all at once: All primary systems online before fading*
Wow.
What the hell? *laughing* What is that?
*laughing*
I mean I know exactly what it was but wooow.
That was terrifying.
That was like the scariest thing I've ever had in Subnautica.
I don't know why Subnautica constantly wants to be a horror game but...
A horror game it be so that's what we shall be dealing with.
Okay, man.
Alright so that's all the time I got for this episode of Subnautica. Sorry I didn't do as much progress on the
new update that I thought but with my... dedication to not cheating, it's harder to make leaps and bounds than
what I used to so we gotta through a more methodical progress. So,
thank you everybody for being patient! And thank you for watching so much!
And as always, I will see you... in the next video!
BUH-BYE!
*Outro: 'Crazy La Paint'*